évaccia Turgeon et directrice générale
du foyer du monde un organisme qui
héberge temporellement les demandeurs
d'asile bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur on
s'était parlé il y a quelques semaines
et déjà vous étiez très inquiète là vous
d'abord sur la fermeture du chemin
Roxane quel est votre réaction sur la
fermeture
mais écoutez c'est quand même pas
nécessairement une surprise il y avait
beaucoup de pression politique on savait
que c'était une grosse enjeu mais pour
nous dans le communautaire c'est
absolument pas une cellule c'est une
solution c'est vraiment de déplacer le
problème parce que des chemins Roxanne
il y en a d'autres qui vont se créer et
plus clandestins en fait que Roxane
l'était donc ce que ça veut dire c'est
que c'est plus de danger pour les gens
qui vont traverser et aussi plus de
d'activités profitable pour les passeurs
qui vont encore plus exploiter ces
personnes vulnérables qui sont les
demandeuses d'asile il y en a à peu près
30 000 qui ont passé par le chemin
Roxane vous dites que d'après vous il va
en avoir presque autant en tout cas
beaucoup qui vont essayer dans les bois
se cacher pendant 14 jours parce
qu'après 14 jours faut comprendre que le
Canada ne pourra pas les retourner aux
États-Unis
c'est exact par contre c'est un petit
peu compliqué là jusqu'à présent ne pas
tout à fait de précision sur comment ce
14 jours là va être prouvé ou voir
calculer parce que c'est un petit peu
difficile si on se cache puis on
traverse de manière irrégulière de
prouver que ça fait 14 jours qu'on est
caché donc ça c'est un point
d'interrogation pour l'instant on attend
d'avoir un peu plus de précisions à ce
sujet là mais c'est sûr que c'est une
suspension en fait du droit d'asile
pendant 14 jours et c'est ça qui est
vraiment le nous choque profondément
mais en même temps alors quel était dans
votre perspective la solution pour le
chemin Roxane parce qu'il y avait un
déséquilibre au Canada c'était qu'au
Québec que ces gens-là arrivaient
c'était quoi la solution alors
c'est pas une question facile c'est sûr
que il y aurait eu manière de faire de
choses des choses plus équilibrées c'est
à dire peut-être plus de chemin du genre
de Roxane ailleurs après on était même
pas là la question pour nous le plus
important le point dans le plus
important pour le communautaire c'était
vraiment que l'entente elle soit
suspendue parce que c'est une entente
qui finalement met obstacle au droit
d'asile un droit qui est international
et qui devrait être inaliénable donc
pour expliquer aux gens et si on avait
suspendu l'entame puisqu'on entendait
des gens dire ça ça aurait voulu dire
que peu importe le lieu de frontière
officielle ou pas un poste douanier
officiel ou pas les gens auraient pu
faire une demande au Canada c'est ça que
ça aurait voulu dire et c'est ce que
vous souhaiteriez vous mais on voudrait
en fait qu'il y ait pas les exceptions
qu'il y a dans l'entente du tiers pays
sûr donc pour pouvoir demander le droit
d'asile parce qu'actuellement les seules
exceptions qui font qu'on peut à un
poste d'entrée officiel
demandé l'asile au Canada et vice-versa
aux États-Unis c'est si on a de la
famille au pays c'est si on est un
mineur non accompagné la troisième est
un petit peu plus exceptionnelle c'est
pour intérêt public donc par exemple
c'est une personne était sous peine de
mort aux États-Unis pour un crime qui
est pas un crime au Canada par exemple
alors mais si on faisait ça vous
craignez pas un afflux
trop important de réfugier et donc une
impossibilité de les encadrer de les
aider une fois parce qu'on le voit les
vos organismes étaient débordés
mais la question c'était que oui on
était débordé mais parce qu'on avait un
manque de ressources s'il y a eu
beaucoup de récupération par rapport à
ce que le communautaire est mis comme
comme crainte qui était qu'on y arrivait
plus mais c'était pas parce qu'on ne
voulait plus accueillir les gens mais
c'est parce qu'on voulait mieux le faire
le concept de capacité d'accueil à mon
sens c'est un ensemble c'est un c'est
plutôt le concept de capacité d'agir qui
devrait primer c'est à dire c'est quoi
la volonté politique pour accueillir ces
gens-là parce que ce qui est arrivé
cette année ou en 2022 si on utilise des
chiffres le plus précisément 2022 c'est
qu'on a reçu quand même moins de
demandeurs d'asile qu'en 2017 et
pourtant 2017 on le très bien fait
l'accueil des gens pourquoi cette
fois-ci ça c'est pas bien fait avec un
nombre plus petit donc moins de gens
c'est c'est une question de volonté
politique et de ressources donc vous
dites rapidement qu'à court terme c'est
vrai que vous étiez débordé mais qui a
moyen terme le Québec vous vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec
l'opinion qui dit que on ne peut plus en
recevoir même un seul de plus le
commander la ministre absolument puis je
trouve que c'est un non sens de dire non
à des gens justement comme le disait
tout à l'heure à Michel SOG qui ont de
la famille ici qui parle français ce
sont exactement les critères
habituellement qui devraient faire
qu'une personne peut venir au Québec et
là actuellement on fait juste refuser
tout le monde sans aucun regard humain
je dirais on oublie que ce sont des
humains
on va reparler Eva graciaturgeon
directrice générale du foyer du monde
une organisme qui héberge des demandeurs
d'asile et des migrants Montréal merci
de nous avoir parlé merci merci